so I have compiled some of my favorite
clips from their vlogs I want you to
take me through some of these moments
how you came up with the idea what
happened how you thought about the final
product ne T basically that you have I'm
about these clips they're my personal
favorite moments from your videos great
yeah I'm ready messing with Alex's Pat
is probably the worst prank you could
possibly pull yeah okay so let me give
you some context so this is when Alex
and I bought a bunny for a bit that we
were doing and we're gonna return the
bunny or give it to a friend or
something when we were when we were done
with her and Alex fell in love with her
like really bad and it was really really
it's been six hours and in love with his
bunny so then I think a couple weeks
later I hired an actor to come play this
guy off Craigslist and I told him I sold
the bunny and that was bad I don't I
feel really bad I can't believe I even
posted this out started crying anyone in
his room and I joined the cameras off
because it was like it was pretty sad
and I actually feel bad I didn't know
that he liked the bunny bad so oh yeah I
feel bad
how is Bailey now by the way everyone
she's good she's honestly she's like a
big cat now it's not like a cute bunny
she's literally this big like she's
she's huge it's a love still real
between Alex and Bailey at least yeah
especially because she's coming more
closer to being a human side oh yeah
yeah so it's becoming more and more
possible that maybe one day that
something seen that sparked I have any
actual phobia like no joke dead-ass
phobia of caterpillars I hate that I
feel bad about this - okay so Emma made
a video where she said she had a phobia
of caterpillars and I didn't know what
that Matt I thought it was like I'm
scared caterpillars I didn't know I was
like I'm hilarious it was fun but then I
was like oh wow she's really scared
about I'm sorry I'm a how did you put
you just randomly watching her videos
and he's no no I'm I started shooting
with us and then everybody started
tweeting at me she hates it I'm like
okay I got to do it I'll do it
and I heard those caterpillars out from
San Diego because they're hard to get
and it was like
hundred $60 uber for them to get here
and I was waiting for them for like
three hours I was falling their trip
these caterpillar sitting on the back of
an SUV I got a I got a black car for
them of course yeah absolutely ready and
happy how much is this bad 90,000 Hermes
crooked 90,000 what the Jeffrey star
video you guys went to his house crazy
you lost the question we were all
wondering what was that like
I mean Jeffrey stars entire life is
insane like bonkers I mean I don't know
I remember leaving leaving that house
and I just like what did I just like
walk in here it was like it was like
being in a movie it's insane
I'm interested together are also very
dangerous oh very dangerous yeah we are
you they're only allowed to hang out
once every four months yeah it's because
they're just there just to tortoise and
he would end up very very important or
it just hangs out with him that's why I
keep her away precious standing next to
you mixed Rochelle look like a
completely sane person this is my fav is
good the make-out prank it's my favorite
video this is like the one like if like
people don't know my videos I love
showing on this this is the best
reaction I've gotten to anything you're
really so good such and I'm such a big
fan of reactions like that's like why I
surprise people of things this was my
absolute favorite I remember getting I
remember sitting behind the camera I was
like I was so happy and how did you
think about cuz you went through a lot
of effort you put on a whole fake
commercial to have your friend make out
with Jason without him realizing it yeah
I had I had my friend make out with a 45
year old yeah without but for the second
time it was great I'm super super
honored to be able to do that it's not a
lot of work to put together I mean he
had a whole fake crew yeah it was like
yeah it was like a week of planning wow
she's pretty pretty big for my videos
because I don't usually do that but ya
know it was and we finished it on
Saturday so I had all of Sunday off and
that's the only day I remember where I
was like I have this day off like I was
like there's nothing I can shoot because
I've done and I was like do I fly back
to Chicago
do I go to Hawaii for a night I was like
on another planet
dude you're so overdramatic man for
dramatic David he wants the overdramatic
I'll show you overdramatic this was in
my floor in xx video we drove to the
desert we drove three hours to get this
Alex had to blow the tables up by
shooting like this like box I was like
this big with the sniper rifle he's
never shot a sniper ever and there was a
guy behind him standing with a detonator
in case he missed but the guy behind him
said he didn't even have to push it
because Alex actually hit it and there's
this first time shooting a gun and that
scared me so much he got on his first
hit that was so much fun and how much
work was they to set up all those tables
that's what the first time I thought
that's what I yeah and it was so windy
out there and we were setting up all
that like screwing all the tables it was
worth I thought that was like 40 seconds
it was worth it for sure crazy that we
pulled this off this is a video where we
convinced our friend who was scared of
basically everything in it and
everything he was scared of natural
disasters so we convinced him that the
San Andreas Fault has ruptured and we
had fake police come to our house and
then when he walked outside of the house
there was 30 extras packing their cars
like they were leaving like in our
neighborhood he freaked out he texted me
that night after he's like I can't trust
you anymore and like serious like he
didn't want to talk to me when I ever
see him again I have to go apologize to
him and then I had to call his mother
and I had to call his dad and apologize
to both of them because it was like
really serious
it was pretty scarred from from the he
was I think he's over it now but like
yeah in the moment it was bad how did
you I mean I know Jason's really close
with Brandon so how did he feel seeing
poor Brandon to go through all that I
think he loved it yeah I think my
problem with his everybody in Brandon's
family and Brandon but no it was fun and
I'm sure he likes him out I mean it made
for a really really good video so
exciting so excited did he ever get a
date again with that girl that you
really know your stuff I really okay
that's the same yeah we had to cancel a
date that he had with a girl because he
wasn't gonna come over that night so I
had to find the girl at the find her
number and at the caller and be like can
you please cancel on the date with
Brandon and she did and she actually
never called him a gun and there
against which kind of sucks but now he
has a girlfriend so he's happy so you
welcome Brandon as far as ideas where in
your mind do they come from the mind of
david dobrik because some of our really
really wild a lot of my friends help me
with ideas - yeah
and I think like a big like
misconception with all of this is like
you have so many ideas to do things I
cannot stress enough that every single
day we start filming we do not have a
single idea of what we're doing like I
have to post a video tomorrow and
there's nothing in it so far and I have
no idea what I'm doing absolutely no
idea what I'm doing and we have no ideas
planned we have not even a single idea
that's like I'd be cool to do we
literally have nothing and that's what
sucks and is so great about this is that
it's just like every day it's like
waking up like being shot out of a
cannon and being okay learn to fly right
now
[Music]